[Music]
spring is just a few days away and you
know what that means it's time for
spring cocktails with the help of
TaylorMade Productions the sponsors of
this segment joining us to share some
drinks for spring and one for St
Patrick's Day is our entertaining expert
Paul's on so great to see you Paul good
to see you so the only thing better than
one Paul is two paws what's that over
there well let me explain so Friday is
St Patrick's Day in a Jameson Irish
whiskey the only Irish whiskey to enjoy
on St Patrick's Day has a spto program
going so that's St Patrick's time off
instead of going to work on St Patrick's
Day you can get a desk a decoy that's
right you put this in your place at your
cubicle and go out drink some Jameson
enjoy St Patrick's Day and you can find
this at
jamisonto.com so make a drink party and
put your desk decoy up and voila oh my
God perfect St Patrick's Day is so fun
and speaking of Jameson tell us about
this cocktail over here so this is an
espresso Martini it is one shot of
espresso one shot of Kahlua and one shot
of Jameson Irish whiskey Shake It Up and
voila perfect St Patrick's Day or spring
cocktail and a great way to keep you
awake keep you going through the day
keep it going keep it going right all
right we're talking spring too so let's
move on but the drink is also green so
it could be for St Patrick's Day too yes
we have a delicious drink with the
Glenlivet single melt single malt scotch
whiskey so this is the number one single
malt scotch whiskey in the world it's
absolutely delicious it has some fruit
to it it has some creaminess to it so
what I did here is I put some matcha
some cream of coconut some lime juice
and some of the delicious Glenlivet
Founders Reserve in there and this is
the perfect spring cocktail people often
think that Scotch is that just winter no
no no this is a great mixable cocktail
right here and a great mixable Scotch
with the Glenlivet single malt scotch
whiskey and this is a founders of
Reserve paying homage to the ogs who
created this delicious number one scotch
I love that a great way to kind of make
a lighter drink for the spring and it's
just so pretty almost too pretty to
drink but I don't drink it
we have a delicious lower proof cocktail
right here with some spritzes with Lele
so Lele is a wine-based aperitif from
the Bordeaux region of France 85 wine
based from Bordeaux and then 15 Spirit
base macerated with Botanicals in Fruit
so the rose I love the Blanc I love so
this is just some soda water and some of
the Lele Rose flavor so it's lower proof
perfect for brunch perfect for spring
actually it's perfect all year round who
am I kidding Jillian I have to say that
that'd be great to drink on a patio I
like that spring spritzes can't go wrong
what it is about and lastly I'm loving
even just the display you have over here
but tell me about this drink we are
having some delicious tequila we're
actually doing a tequila mojito so I
have some agave in here I have some mint
I have some lime juice and then some
Avion tequila so avian tequila is a
really delicious tequila this is their
silver it starts um in the highlands of
Jalisco Mexico it is 100 blue Weber
Agave that has been maturing for five
years and then it's cooked for two days
in slow roasted absolutely delicious
it's got that nice roasted Agave on the
nose it's got a little spice to it it's
perfect this is my everyday elevated
tequila for spring and you can never go
wrong with the Mojito and let's switch
things up forget the rum let's do some
Avion tequila in a delicious mojito for
spring wow a tequila mojito Paul thank
you so much for all of these cocktails a
great way to start with St Patrick's Day
and just lead us into spring so thank
you so much for being here thank you
Jillian cheers the only thing left to
say is cheers
thank you
well